toilet bathroom restroom the ladies room
boys room blue powder room washroom the
flush toilet was a transformative
invention it made Europe's growing
cities two centuries ago livable however
the technology some people say is
perhaps a bit outdated it uses drinkable
water to flush away nutrients and there
are people who are looking for new ways
to process human waste that would be
more ecologically sustainable and could
bring sanitation to developing countries
where currently is not available the
current system uses drinkable water to
flush away human waste it's often called
flush and forget by sanitation experts
that has its advantages people in their
homes don't need to deal with the waste
but it does sort of push the problem
downstream it costs them money and
energy to clean that drinkable water to
be able to release it back into the
environment and those things can be in
short supply especially in regions where
water and fresh water is in short supply
sewage systems are either unsustainable
or it simply doesn't make sense to build
new ones another problem is that the
waste contains pollutants and nutrients
that cause environmental problems
downstream phosphorous and nitrogen are
the biggest problems those can cause
algae blooms and dead zones in waterways
and often the current system mixes
household waste and human waste with
industrial waste which makes things even
more complicated to clean up on the
other end the ideal toilet 2 point 0
which is some which is what some experts
are calling it would be decentralized so
that it's easy to use in rapidly
urbanizing areas and wouldn't have to be
connected to a larger system it would be
relatively inexpensive so that it's easy
to use in poor areas where sanitation is
lacking it will use little water so that
it can be used in dry regions and it
will ideally recover some of the
nutrients and even the energy that's
present in human waste phosphorous and
nitrogen are two key components of human
waste and those are also key components
of fertilizer and if you could find a
way to recover those you could reuse
them
feces especially contains carbon and so
can be used as an energy source that
could in theory be used to run the
system and of course we also need the
solution to be hygienic no odors no mess
and easy and attractive for people to
use one of the simplest technologies for
treating human waste in a new way is the
composting toilet and this has actually
been around for several decades there's
even a book called the humanure handbook
that talks about how to install a
composting toilet in your home the
composting toilet uses aerobic bacteria
to digest the contents of the toilet and
in the end produces compost that can be
used easily in horticultural settings on
non edible plants and with some extra
processing even in agricultural settings
another technology that many people say
makes a lot of sense is a separation
toilet that separates urine and feces at
the collection point that makes
everything easier to process it's easier
to collect the nutrients from the urine
and recover clean water it's also easier
to treat the feces on the other end they
don't emit as many odors when they're
not mixed with urine and it's a smaller
volume so it ends up being easier to
disinfect and treat that part of the
human waste one of the things that has
brought new energy to the field is the
fact that the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation has started what they're
calling the reinventing the toilet
challenge that has inspired a number of
researchers who aren't usually involved
in sanitation engineering to try new
ideas to come up with this ideal toilet
two point O one team for example is
trying hydrothermal carbonization that's
a relatively new chemical process that
turns it into a coal slurry that then
makes it easy to recover clean water and
energy challenges remain of course
getting people to use new toilets is no
small hurdle people hope that if the
solution is attractive enough it will
market itself this is an issue that all
societies all people have to deal with
we don't like to talk about it much but
finding a new way to go more
ecologically would be a benefit to both
developing countries and the
industrialized world muthu closet the WC
and by
your facilities John lavatory the lash
porta potti boge potty urinal sometimes
people call the actual toilet and what
it for some reason